to talk about CAR-T-cells and allotransplant. It's kind of funny, you know, the leukemia docs
listen to the lymphoma and myeloma docs talk about whether autotransplantation is dead. And
in the ALL world, we're trying to figure out how to get rid of the use of allogeneic transplantation
and do CAR-T-cells get us there. And I'm going to make a case that right now, probably not yet.
So we all know that CAR-T-cells are very important for management of relapsed refractory ALL,
but the pivotal trials that led to the approval of brexit cell and OB cell, which are our main
broadly available CAR-T-cells for adults, left a lot of unanswered questions, primarily because
both studies included a substantial portion of patients who had previously had an allotransplant
and it didn't specify whether patients should receive a consolidative ALL after the CAR-T-cell.
So we have a lot of questions from these studies. And there's a few different ways that one can
receive a CAR-T-cell for relapsed refractory ALL. You can either receive it as destination therapy
without a transplant, you can receive a consolidative allotransplant after the CAR-T-cell,
or you may receive the CAR-T-cell
for relapsed refractory ALL.
a post-transplant relapse. And then in rare cases, one could consider a second transplant
after that scenario. So if we look at the data from the ZUMA3 study, which led to the approval
of brexit cell, there did not appear to be a different outcome on the left side for patients
who did or did not have a prior allotransplant, nor did there appear to be a difference on the
right side for patients who had a consolidative allotransplant or not. But this is a relatively
small study. There are only 51 patients in the phase two. And when we combine those who got
the pivotal dose in phase one, it's still only 78 patients. So this really wasn't designed to
answer this question. On the FELIX study, which led to the approval of OB cell, there is no
difference in outcomes if we censor or not for the use of subsequent alginate transplantation.
However, in a multivariate analysis presented by Jay Park at ASCO last year, we do see that
there is a significant impact, apparently, to having a prior alginate transplant before
receiving OB cell. And so if we look at the outcomes for alginate transplantation for
relapsed refractory ALL, you see here the bar for C2 and beyond, it really is a long-term survival,
about 50%. And to me, this is the bar that needs to be overcome by CAR-T cells for us to say that
we're going to relegate allotransplantation in this particular setting. And those CAR-T cells
don't appear to be getting us there. So because there are so many unanswered questions from these
clinical trials, it's really incumbent upon us as a community to gather our data in the real world
to address some of these questions. We're now doing this with ALL.
through the ROCA consortium, which is aggregating data from more than 40 U.S. institutions.
And the first publication came out a little more than a year ago from the first 189 patients
infused in the commercial setting with Brexacel. And we saw that the outcomes really recapitulated
the ZUMA3 trial, showing that this is a reliable data set to start answering some of these
unanswered questions. And even from this analysis of the first 189 patients,
we can see that there appears in the real world to be a benefit
both to having had a prior transplant or to having a subsequent algenic transplant after Brexacel
in the real world. And so we wanted to answer this question as cleanly as possible. So we
continue to gather more patients in this database. There's now about 350 patients
who have received Brexacel in the real world. We found 164 patients, all pH-B cell ALL,
who achieved an MRD-negative remission, either flow or NGS, after the CAR-T cell as measured at
one month. And we
broke these patients down into those who had never had a transplant, those who had a post-CAR-T cell
consolidated allotransplant, or those who had had a pre-CAR-T cell transplant, namely they got the
CAR-T cell for post-transplant relapse. We actually excluded the very small number of patients who had
two transplants. This doesn't happen very frequently in the real world. We didn't think that only nine
patients would really lead to a reliable assessment. So when we break these patients down, we see that
there were substantially larger patients who had a pre-CAR-T cell as measured at one month. And we
also have a larger number of young patients who had a post-CAR-T cell consolidated allotransplant. And
there were more patients who had a post-CAR-T cell consolidated allotransplant who had non-CNS
extramedullary disease. On the other side, we see that there were more patients of advanced age who
never had a transplant in this setting. We really wanted to address the question, for those who had
a transplant before and then relapsed and then got to CAR-T cells, whose T cells are making those
CAR-T cells? So we obtained chimerism data for,
as many of these patients as we could. This is not collected necessarily systematically at all centers.
We were able to get data on 28 patients. We found that the majority of these patients were indeed
full donor chimeras at the time that they had their apheresis, meaning that their CAR-T cells
were indeed allogeneic CAR-T cells. So does this have an impact?
So if we look at this, these outcomes with about a year of follow-up, we can see
that at one year, the best outcomes are for those who had a post-CAR-T cell consolidated allotransplant.
78% one-year survival. Next is those patients who had a prior transplant before the CAR-T cells
at 58%. And the worst outcome is in those who never had a transplant. Now, of course, we can't
directly compare these curves to one another because there's an immortal time bias for those
who went on to receive a subsequent transplant. So if we landmark at day 73, which is the median
time to a post-CAR-T cell transplant, we can see very interestingly that those who achieve and
remission until two and a half months after CAR-T cells enjoy the same benefit if they had a prior
transplant as if they had a post-CAR-T cell transplant. So there does seem to be an impact
to receiving allogeneic CAR-T cells in the setting. And, you know, unfortunately, those patients who
never had a transplant have the worst outcomes. With this one year of follow-up, we don't yet
see overall survival differences, but we will continue to follow. So we did want to try and
address the question with the data that we have, who may be the best candidate for never
receiving an allotransplant when using CAR-T cells for relapsed refractory ALL. And interestingly,
the outcomes are best for patients of more advanced age. So patients over age 60 here are
doing better, patients who have non-PH-like disease, and those who are MRD negative prior
to the apheresis, meaning that they got salvage therapy, had a great response to it, went on to
receive an apheresis and a CAR-T cell, and then did very well. So I'll just conclude by saying
one of our findings is the vast majority of patients who get CAR-T cells, they're not
getting allogeneic CAR-T cells in the post-transplant relapse setting, are getting allogeneic CAR
T cells. And those patients have a better outcome than patients who never have a transplant. This
raises some very interesting questions. Is it because they're invigorating some kind of
graft-versus-leukemia effect? Are the T cells simply of better fitness because they have not
gone through multiple cycles of chemotherapy? Or is there something else going on? Patients who
did not have a prior transplant and got Brexacel in the real-world setting did better,
if they received a consolidative allo. And on the basis of these data, the Rocket Consortium
does recommend that if a patient has never had an allotransplant and they're receiving
Brexacel for relapse, that they should probably go on to a consolidated allotransplant.
But if you wanted to pick the people who you might avoid transplant, it's going to be the
older patients, non-PH-like disease, who have a great response to salvage before the apheresis,
and there you might be able to avoid it. Hopefully with additional data, we'll have even
more precise measures for predicting who can do well without transplant.
And with that, I'm going to thank everyone from the Rocket Consortium who collected these data.
This is a lot of work at each of the centers, and it wouldn't be possible for us to answer
these questions without everyone's help. So thank you very much.